bueno esta visita de rafael grossi
angela era muy importante porque porque
estas cámaras de vigilancia que estaban
dentro de estas plantas nucleares que se
estaban desactualizando muchas de ellas
no habían se habían retirado muchas de
ellas no estaban funcionando como se
debía por falta de acceso a estos
inspectores pertenecientes a esta
organización que dejaron de estar
presentes en irán desde comienzos del
año así que en esto en vista de que la
semana entrante también hay una reunión
de todos los gobernadores desde la
organización
internacional de energía atómica e irán
y va a ser el punto central de esa
conversación con la preocupación del
poco acceso que tienen a estas plantas
nucleares y solas y también con la poca
vigilancia que hay pues esta avenida de
rafael grossi y la de las en la
confirmación de irán de que podrán
entrar inspectores para renovar estas
cámaras para cambiar las tarjetas que
graban lo que están viendo de estas
plantas nucleares pues es importante
bueno catalina y pese al acuerdo siguen
las tensiones que sigue ahora en las
negociaciones del nuevo pacto
bueno en la
visita de hoy se dice que rafael grossi
va a volver a visitar teherán en las
próximas semanas para hacer ya
conversaciones mucho más profundas sobre
los dos compromisos de irán en este
acuerdo nuclear hay una gran
preocupación porque cada vez acumula más
uranio enriquecido y cada vez retrocede
más en esos compromisos que tiene el
acuerdo nuclear también se está tratando
de acelerar que se vuelva a la mesa n se
está en esas negociaciones para volver a
reactivar el acuerdo nuclear retiremos
que éstas quedaron casi muertas cuando
donald trump se retiró del acuerdo
nuclear en el 2018 y desde la llegada al
presidente joe biden se han vuelto a
reactivar estas conversaciones pero han
quedado estancadas o paralizadas con el
nuevo gobierno de brain rise y así que
estamos en un punto de inflexión esa
visita ha sido importante porque
demuestra que hay voluntad no solamente
a la comunidad internacional sino
también de ir a devolver a la mesa y
poder volver a reactivar no solamente
este acuerdo nuclear sino que también
sus compromisos con la organización
internacional de energía atómica